you know what i think you do a great job  of that  i don't do a good job of and that's like  you have so much [ __ ] going on so many  companies you got your music but i  always feel like you do a great job of  balancing family  and work  you got to how did you figure like  that's not an easy thing to figure out  how to do like how did you  how do you do that so well well i just  know that like at the end of the day our  kids only know what we teach them and  you know like i just  i really love my kids i love the family  and i just try to that's like actually  the balance i need to keep going because  as spread then as i am bro like i'll  burn out sooner or  when i'm with the fam later just know  that's the balance i need to to keep  working like this it's tough to work  like this bro  super super draining